dème les gens c'est thibaut in shape en
fait c'est fabien olicard c'est encore
un proc
ouais mais je vais aller là bas comme ça
on aura plus de lumière pour faire à
nouveau casse tête
c'est celui ci parce que oui c'est pas
parce qu'on est au mois d'août que les
mercredis matin il n'y a pas un nouveau
casse-tête à 6 heures du matin sur la
chaîne
je suis ravi puisque je vois vraiment
que ça vous plaît aussi bien les castes
et sur la chaîne youtube que sur mon
instagram après les gros plans que je
vous fais n'hésitez pas à les voir si
vous n'avez pas vu les deux vidéos se
complète toujours est temps que j'y suis
merci à tous et qui m'envoient des
photos sur instagram 2e à la plage ou en
vacances en train de lire mon monde mon
deuxième livre celui là bas c'est trop
cool voilà je suis ravi qu'il vous
plaise autant que le premier c'était le
but si vous l'avez pas jouer le lien
dans la description de castets un petit
peu la forme d'un fruit et c'est
sûrement pour ça qu'ils ont appelé le
casse tête citron parce que c'est un
petit peu l'air d'un citron ça ce serait
le corps du fruit et ici au dessus on
aurait la tige alors en le sculpteur
rapidement on se rend compte qu'il ya
trois partis distincts c'est-à-dire qui
représente la tige est clairement de
composé de deux parties reliées par une
boule et le corps c'est cette partie là
qui est unique et complètement solidaire
tient qu à cet intermédiaire plus et je
comprends le fait qu'ils sont internes à
dire plus parce que on comprend tout de
suite le but faut défaire les trois
parties et faut être capable de les
refaire derrière c'est le but des
casse-têtes le défaire complètement
étape une l'euro perd complètement étape
2 c'est ce qui sert à prouver aussi
qu'on a compris le mécanisme du casse
tête
mais de la manière dont a été faite la
partie solidaire avec les rainures qu'on
voit ici ici ici ici on se rend bien
compte qu'il va y avoir un chemin à
parcourir pour pouvoir le sortir ce qui
effectivement que paraît très simple
ou peut-être peut paraître très dur ça
on ne sait jamais à chaque fois comment
ces vidéos en tout cas c'est la première
fois que je vois un casse tête qui
ressemble à un aliment
là en l'occurrence un fruit et je trouve
ça particulièrement stylé c'est pour ça
que je les prie d'ailleurs c'est qu'il
m'a beaucoup plu quand je le vois j'aime
bien l'idée
j'aime bien le concept parce que ces
deux tiges là sont attachés par une
boule jeu
je comprends pas tout à fait le système
encore mais j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
une barre qui sort de celui là donc ce
serait là la tige avec la barre qui
rentre dans cette tige là qui elle a un
trou pour recevoir la tige c'est le
principe de l'emboîtement quand on est
tous en train de se marier derrière nos
écrans je ne sais pas donc ouais j'aime
bien le principe et je le trouve même
très joli le travail du métal et est
plutôt bien fait et donc c'est parti on
va essayer de le défaire donc je pense
déjà que c'est impossible de faire
passer les deux tiges par le même chemin
je pense qu'il faut qu'ils aient deux
chemins opposés en fait mais assez
logiquement
ok donc si ça c'est sa position initiale
ou ici l'en but et a causé la boule et
si il est en butte et a causé la tige et
si on le pilote de 90 degrés il perd
facilement là pour le coup les tiges
arrive à se séparer une fois
donc en fait ça va être ça c'est de
trouver ah oui d'accord ok mais même
s'ils s'en séparer une fois je peux pas
libéré réellement la tige du trou je
sais pas si je suis bien claire geoffray
des gros plans de tout ça aussi sur sur
instagram
je pense que je vais le crack est assez
facilement du coup je me demande si je
vais pas vous faire linverse de ce que
je fais d'habitude à savoir essayer de
faire tout chemin dans ma tête pour le
crack et essayer de le faire après d'un
coup sans chercher
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je vous
mets un sondage ici et vous me dites
qu'on par contre le problème c'est que
c'est que je peux pas dire le résultat
du sondage je vais essayer de pressentir
le résultat du sondage
ok on fait ça ça marche donc deux
parties qui peuvent pivoter à chaque
fois le but c'est de virer cette pouvoir
les voir
[Musique]
ok je pense que c'est bon j'ai juste un
doute sur la fin je n'arrive pas bien à
voir s'il va falloir que je passe tous
par là où seulement l'un des deux du
coup je me le tente donc quart de tour
90° en ouvre on ouvre quart de tour 90
degrés on passe on passe quart de tour
90 degrés ici 180 on sort lui puis pour
lui ont fait clac clac clac clac boum
c'est craqué j'ai craqué parce que ça a
été cracké alors là vous dit peut-être
dans l'espace commentaire qu'il n'était
pas si difficile que ça je suis d'accord
intermédiaire plus je dirais plutôt
intermédiaire - voire moyen assez moyen
mais ça c'est plutôt cool quand vous
avez un casse tête un casque crâne comme
il y en a qui disent que vous pressentez
moyens vous pouvez essayer de vous
challenge est comme ça en vous disant ok
j'essaye de faire tout le parcours en
visualisation 3d dans ma tête et après
j'essaie de le faire une fois sam
arrêter une seule fois et sans erreur du
coup je suis assez content de m'être
donné ce défi là parce que je crois que
j'aurais été déçu je sais même pas si
j'aurais mis la vidéo si j'avais trouvé
ça aussi rapidement mais on n'a fini que
la première étape
donc il faut finir la deuxième étape en
vrai c'est pas mal parce que c'est assez
joli
en termes de symétrie tout est jeu à oui
voilà j'étais en train d'essayer de me
rappeler comment était la position
initiale
c'est ça qui est dur dans les casses
têtes nouvelles c'est vraiment quelle
était la position initiale la boule
était là et l'hôte était là je pense que
pour le remettre ce sera pas la même
quand même ça me paraît plus malins
d'essayer de commencer par lui et du
coup lui
je vais leur mettre ici
donc lui a balancé ça marche oppermann
histoire elle remettre ici
comme ça lui je le rentre là je pense
qu'il faut commencer voilà par les
emboîter dès le départ il retrouve
annonça marche pas mon truc mais
quelques creux qu'il avait tout compris
il il a juste cru qu'il avait tout
compris en fait ça va pas mon histoire
il faut forcément que ça ça a commencé
comme ça
mais si je l'aimé là à ce moment là à ce
moment là tu vois un stade pourra pas
marcher pour aller le remettre
entièrement parce que si je pars dès 2
ans maintenant ça paie ça peut être une
bonne technique
oui clac clac clac clac clac clac clac
clac clac clac clac et là à 180 clac
clac et nous avons un citron
merveilleusement rohff et comme disait
barracuda j'adore parce qu'un plan se
déroule sans accroc c'est vrai et c'est
pas barracuda d'ailleurs qui dit ça
c'est et hannibal
c'est dans les années 80 90 bon bah
écoute super cool je suis trop content
je vais le garder je le ferai pas
souvent mais ça c'est un casse tête je
ne pense que je vais pas mal offrir au
soin aux fans de casse tête parce que le
côté citron et chemins étaient assez
intéressant le côté de pouvoir se défier
en ce challenger à l'avant a essayé de
le faire en 3d et je l'offrirai aussi à
des gens qui veulent débuter en
casquette
parce que du coup ça serait impossible à
résoudre même si tu n'as pas compris
comment tu l'a résolu tu peux
t'entraîner pour comprendre la mécanique
de résolution est beaucoup de fois le
mot résoudre conjuguées de plein de
manières différentes ça fait plaisir
la semaine prochaine par contre ce sera
moins de la rigolade parce qu'on va
prendre un casse tête de difficultés
extrêmes mercredi prochain 6 heures sur
la chaîne n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
s'est pas fait d'excès la cloche de
liker cette vidéo si elle vous a plu
cette vidéo était paru sur dailymotion
un petit peu en avance puisque ma chaîne
secondaire sur dailymotion si tu veux
voir il ya le lien dans la description
merci à très bientôt ciao